- You also do a very specific impression.
What is your impression?
- Oh, yeah. My impression is...
I don't know if you know, but in Germany,
all the movies from around
the world are dubbed.
Dubbing is big in Germany.
And we have like.
There is a voice for Eddie Murphy.
It's a very... It's voice
where when, a german voice,
When this guy talks on the street,
everyone would say, "It's Eddie Murphy."
- Oh, because he does
all the Eddie Murphy?
- He does all the Eddie Murphy stuff.
- They hire the same person to do, Oh.
And he sounds like...
Eddie Murphy in Germany sounds like this,
like, you know like (speaks German).
And its like.
- (women laughing)
Yes.
- I can't wait to have Eddie
Murphy back on the show!
- Yeah, because,
- So, you show him that.
- If you would do that on his street,
when he would say, (speaks German)
Everyone would say, "It's Eddie Murphy.
Oh my God!
- It's like a Jamaican version.
Well, this is actually our
audience warm-up comedian,
is Ruben Irvin
and he's amazing.
He used to voice the character of Donkey
at Universal Theme Parks.
He's amazing at Eddie Murphy.
So could Ruben give you like a line
and you dub it into German for us?
- Yes, I can do this.
- Go ahead.
- Okay.
- (imitating Eddie Murphy) You
know I really like parfait.
You know when somebody would say,
"Hey you want some parfait?
They be like, "Hell no,
I don't want no parfait."
Parfait is delicious. (laughs)
(audience applauding)
- That's amazing.
- It was pretty fast, but in
Germany would sound like this.
(speaks german)
(women laughs)
- I kinda wanna see all
American films in German now.
I just want people to be dubbing them.